joining us now on the continent attire
Coach's Corner he's the head coach the
Georgetown Hoyas Patrick Ewing 19 to 14
on the year lost in the first round of
the NIT
let's make way for one of the greatest
players in basketball he looked like you
could give me about five to seven
minutes right now no those days are long
gone
when's the last time you played
basketball like pick up it's been a lot
of years a friend of mine that went to
Georgetown with his grandmother used to
always tell him that getting old ain't
for punks and my body has gotten old so
those days I may get out there my
shoulder a move but playing pickup those
days are long gone what is the ones the
singular highlight that you want us to
show or if somebody says Patrick Ewing
that's the one highlight you would want
us to see well you know I've been
blessed to be doing playing basketball
for a lot of years but now I'm in the
other phase of my life I'm a coach so I
think right now I don't I wouldn't want
to show anything from me when I was
playing I've had a lot of great memories
a lot of great I've done a lot of great
things in terms of playing but right now
it's coaching and you know we've had two
significant wins last year which is
beating Marquette and being filling over
two ranked teams at the time so I guess
those two those two things would be the
highlight right now of my my coaching
career you had some fun freshmen this
year yet you had fun team there yes I
you know it's funny when I when I got
here yesterday you know a few folks was
saying that to me you you know you had
some great freshmen is that I said yes
when I started here the year I had hair
you know those guys they're good in
their bed you know they've they've had a
great year for us but you know there
still was a learning curve they still
had to learn the difference between high
school and in college and they they
believe in which is a good which is why
I recruited them that they they are that
good that they can let Superman they can
leap tall buildings with a single bound
they won't make too many mistakes and
you had to you know sometimes put them
in their place tell them they're young
you know the things that you got away
with high school you cannot get away
into it with in college and every level
that you go up it's gonna be even that
much harder
I saw where Zion Williamson is gonna
have this bidding war between Nike and
Adidas you know maybe a hundred million
dollars what was your first shoe
contract at adidas it was adidas yeah it
was a deed you remember what I don't
even remember what the numbers were it
was between Nike and Adidas and
unfortunately Deiters one out I only
wore the shoe for two years then they
told me that you're not the player that
we thought you were gonna be so they
wanted to reduce my my contracts I said
no just buy me out wait you weren't the
player they thought you write but you
know my first two seasons I got hurt I
got hurt my played 52 games my first
year and I think I played fifth round
right around the same my second year but
you know they just didn't think I was a
player there was gonna I was I was gonna
be so they didn't have faith did you
recruit John I tried I tried to he was
one of the best players in college
college basketball but we didn't have it
wouldn't get close I heard you talking
to coach Cal and he got a lot close and
I
[Laughter]
Calipari said Zion was better than what
he thought that he didn't know he was
gonna be this great I don't think no one
knows how good a player is going to be I
mean he was dominant for this year in
college no one knows how great he's
gonna be at the next level either
but he did have a dominant year a person
that his size and can do the things that
he can do is quickness and all that
those things it was remarkable no one in
college sports could stop him how would
a 20 year old Patrick Ewing go do
against SIA
well he had me I was I think I was about
2:30 at the time and he's 287 feet he
was a lot bigger than I was but I was I
was a lot more athletic then then I am
now so it'll be a battle we were
definitely and also my friend mine which
was a lot different than you know a lot
of kids these days frame of mind you
know I had that mentality that I'm gonna
do everything I can to stop it I didn't
know that when you you got recruited by
North Carolina right and then you went
there and and Michael Jordan is there
when you're there so you're both being
recruited at the same time it already
signed okay he had already committed I
should say he already committed and he
is system one it was there looking at
the school with his mom and dad and I
was one of the first times I got to meet
him and he has been talking trash from
that day and he still has not was every
chance he gets he rubs it in our you
know rub salt on the wound that that you
didn't go I never beat him yeah never be
him didn't beat him in college you know
I have to I have to suck up and yes
you're right but did you play pick up
against Jordan and his street clothes
yes on that recruiting trip how did that
work out he is like you can you could
never dunk on me and I'm in street shoes
and I just rolled up into small also
when you decided when you held that
press conference when you said you were
gonna go to Georgetown
people thought Boston College and then
when that's the room walked out so when
you said Georgetown I have the room wall
though it's like you know this room
being filled with with people fans or
reporters or and when I said my decision
is to attend Georgetown that half the
room just got up and walked out but you
changed the direction of college
basketball you know I just thought that
I chose the school the right school in
terms for me and it was Georgetown and
UCLA UCLA UCLA was my second choice but
they let me get back on the put on that
plan and I'm figuring it's a long flight
from from Boston all the way out here
but I I just felt like I had a great
career I should I should have three
championships but it was just wasn't in
the cards I was fortunate enough to get
away to come away with one and I'm
blessed blessed about this yeah but I
can understand why you didn't want to
stay in Boston because Boston wasn't
nice to you in high school it wasn't and
I didn't know if that plate of roll that
maybe it was best for you to get out of
Boston and not just but not for that no
not for that reason I should say you
know I was a mama's boy you know my mom
she called me she you know she loved me
and I loved her and I thought it was
best for my development if I was to get
away and become a man and DC was far
enough but close enough UCLA was just
too far and I made the right decision
I think we didn't we tell Reggie Miller
that you were going to go to you like
Reggie was like what like he didn't know
that he was really you know upset that
you were gonna go to you silly you could
have played at UCLA when Reggie was
there I'm not sure if we would have
played in the same I think I'm a little
a lot more older than I think one year
later maybe one year yeah so I mean he
was one of the best shooting guards to
come out of come out of there but did
you hate Reggie when you played against
hell yeah you know I didn't get to be
friends till we had we did that that
that uh that spot for him is that movie
that he was doing all uncle drew well
no not that one the one about Monday
they finally beat us even though they
only beat us that one 30 oh okay
yeah we that's when we broke bread and
we we buried the hatchet but you were in
space Jim's the original Sebastian right
right then I got an Oscar for that body
did you was Jordan a decent actor do you
think did a great job you know it's
funny because you know he and I have
gotten to be you know friends throughout
the years and I thought he should have
did a lot more movies but he he had
enough money had enough fame he didn't
do but you had bird you had Charles
Barkley Muggsy Bogues Larry Johnson Sean
Bradley yeah we had a great cast I can't
imagine
we should have teamed up I can't imagine
what that must have been like with
playing games on the set of Space Jam
but we did have fun we hung out we shot
pool we talked trash and like I said you
know Michael is the biggest trash talker
that you would ever meet also Bert also
bird bird is when they both did both
those two are the two biggest trash
talkers you would ever meet but this
bird does she trash talk Jordan advice
for do they you know oh yeah oh they do
okay because I thought they might not
have respect oh I just remember when
Jordan and we were at a golf tournament
and mike has given charles so much grief
oh he said you know hey how many
championships you got and and we're all
sitting there in it that kids it gets a
little serious because mike is pouring
it on how many times you beat me like it
just was like and then Charles couldn't
and you know Charles never had a loss
for work right Charles didn't he
couldn't fire back you know that's like
I said that's his ace in the hole that's
the that's the last thing he's gonna
he's gonna bring out you know but
imagine if you'd beaten Carolina Oh
right there but you know like I said it
wasn't in the cards for us you know
James if it was
for James Worthy everybody talked about
Michael and how Michael was if it wasn't
for J is the word I would have to tapis
James Worthy
yeah people forget because worthy was a
better college player or thought of than
Mike and even Perkins was a great
college player as well absolutely right
but the one that we didn't have anyone
to stop with James word yeah he was too
big too quick I think he had 30
something points against us everyone
else was we have a relatively in check
but we didn't have anyone to stop him
yeah Mike got left open and hit a jumper
hit that shot yeah that was the thought
of it it's always great to see a proud
of what you did at Georgetown hopefully
you're in the NCAA tournament next year
well I'm hoping I'm hoping you know we
take it one step at a time
he's Patrick Ewing the Georgetown head
coach for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]